One day I woke up and
they called my co-founder and
I told him this is not going anywhere.
We can't work like that.
We have full time jobs,
he was working in an advertising agency.
I was working.
I had actually two jobs.
I was working as an analyst,
as a QA engineer.
And I told them we can't do it.
We were doing our full time jobs.
And then on the nights we're
starting this start up.
And we had just one guy
doing the programming.
And we expect him to do all that work.
And this is not going anywhere.
We're just entrepreneurs.
We just want to be there but
we need to commit.
We need to burn the bridges behind us.
And not really have Plan B.
We need to have only Plan A.
We're doing this, and no matter what.
And we both gave notice the same day and
56 days later we got our first investor.
So that was really the moment
that switched everything and
probably if we didn't just quit
our jobs and just go for it.
We probably never
completed the first version
because we would just like
postponing it forever.
And that fuel,
that like fire that gets you going,
that what really made a change for us.